it was just mind-blowing and i was like
oh my god
this is so good so do you get to rip
someone's heart out and i was like
i think i do man
kind of wins beauty this movie grants us
with the one thing that every mortal
kombat fan wants to see and those are
the finishers the fatalities so when you
actually
see yours like play out on screen how
did you react filming it was even
another experience like but seeing it in
the cinema
with the sound and the effects and
everything coming together
it was just mind-blowing i think it's
it's pretty violent i'm lyles is insane
i love it
max has been doing martial arts for over
20 years he's part of
jackie chan's stunt team and he
is a perfectionist we did this twice we
filmed the movie
principal photography before the
pandemic and then we had to do some
additional stuff additional blood
additional fighting during the pandemic
and max did that fatality
uh had to do it twice but many many
times over
and that day he must have done like 30
backflips and then he was walking around
just pouting saying i i don't think i
did the perfect one
and everyone was jaws to the floor
and i don't know if he's gonna live it
down but maybe you can tell him ashley
he has nothing to worry about
it was chef's kiss phenomenal i think
when i had said to friends when i first
got the job i was doing mortal kombat
i i would say overwhelmingly the biggest
comment was oh do you get to rip
someone's heart out
and i was like i think i do man it to be
able to do that
it was fun to say the least but it was
really satisfying and i gotta say it
looks pretty cool
the way i ended up doing it but one of
the things that uh
that i think is really cool about the
film is there are a lot of practical
effects in the film it's not
it's not as cg heavy as you might expect
so you know
there was a bit of puppetry and a bit of
like you know holding a prosthetic heart
and there was like
they were pumping it off screen and so
it was slippery you know
i think you could tell when you watched
the film but it was yeah it wasn't
exactly like i was acting opposite of
tennis ball i mean you are
it was happening in real time we were
watching it yeah it was amazing the
the intricacies of all of that and how
much effort they made it
put into making it real which was also
simon's
vision he was like as little green or
blue screen as possible
but yeah i mean the fatality is the best
i have a couple in there
as well i'd like to say i almost have
one of the most you probably good yeah i
was like
oh my god oh my god this is so good
and then everybody ever did did an
amazing job and then
all the fights story and the final
fights
you know the forest fight in the
beginning when i was on set working i
didn't really think about how it's going
to turn out i just focus on the job
like i need i need to make sure that
everything is right so i'm like i'm
quite perfectionist so i don't want to
get distracted to see
i really checked the monitor to be
honest because i trust the action
director and everybody there so when i
watch it for the first time it was it
was it was crazy it was crazy feeling to
see
that i have high hope like the feeling
that i have
like i hope when people see it first
time on the big screen
or on hbo max they feel the same it
feels like
so much happiness so much proud and then
you know it is unreal
the fate of earth is in our hands so i'm
hoping for a sequel i think we all are
hopefully it let's manifest it's
happening
who's the character you would love to
see in the seat in the sequel or a
character you would love to fight in the
sequel
everybody i would love to fight kung lao
yeah i think it would be interesting if
either one of us would choose to jump on
the bat side and then we would fight
against each other that'd be cool
i would like to see a scarlet i think
scarlet is a really cool character
i like the blood bending idea um
i like fight smoke that would be really
cool i think that that's a really
interesting character
and of course noob cybot if the sequel
leads down that road as many roads that
could go down but noob saibot
i think is uh one of the coolest
characters in the game
and uh i would love to to try my hand i
would like to see
katana and jackie briggs i want to see
some more
women of color in the movie and i also i
got beat for bakara
i just feel like that would be a hell of
a fight between jackson mccarthy so
i want to see that too i want to see
that one but there's so many
there's just so many there's so many
incredible characters and
and the universe is so rich that this
could go on forever
and in some ways i hope it does i would
love to see johnny cage
i would love to see him spa with josh uh
you know whoever that person might be
i'm like in the middle of that action
too
with kano and johnny cage and these two
massive egocentric
lunatics i just think what of who to see
that'd be fun
i'll add cassie catch to it as well i
think that's you just kind of flirt
well yeah i mean i feel like that is
that age appropriate i don't know
just there's so much fun to be had with
the millennial view
of this world's point yeah you know what
i mean i just feel like
that's a very current she's a prison
through which we could see the
you know the the world uh you know from
a really contemporary standpoint
so yeah the cages i don't know we'll say
the cages
i loved it that you even think kano
would think
what something would be whether he'd
even consider something to be
age-appropriate as if
it's just me that's just josh i'm
yeah doesn't give about anything he's a
bastard but yeah i just want to make
sure that um
i uh yeah and then kano
yeah good okay do you have a fan casting
in mind of like who you would like to
see play johnny cage
ryan reynolds would be perfect that's a
good one
it has to be like yeah like ultimate
like yeah
that's a really cool actually i love it
i think the original was like based off
jean-claude van damme
i do bring in some more female
characters
into the realm though because there's so
many great female characters in mortal
kombat
it would be nice to actually even out
the team a little bit
you